Personal dietary choices are an
extraordinarily important cause - in fact,
they're the single biggest cause of lost
years of healthy life in the developed
world. And they're a really strong
competitor for the single biggest cause
in the developing world too. Unhealthy dietary choices are
five times as important as physical
inactivity as a driver of premature
death and disease. And so for that reason,
and they're the major thing behind this
skyrocketing rate of global obesity. This
is in the US but the rate, the global
rate, the curve looks pretty similar.
And for this reason cost-effective
scaleable interventions to get people to
change their health, their dietary
choices are a very important scientific
priority. They have been for about 30
years. And by the way, the changes
don't have to be big to be very
important. So for example, there was an
estimate published in The Lancet in 2011
that as of 2011 as little as a 20
calorie per person reduction on average
across the US and UK would have gotten
those countries to 1990s levels of
obesity within three years. It's a tiny
tiny change. But it's got to be on a
massive scale, and it's got to be
sustained. And so because it's been this
scientific priority, there have been lots
of people who've tried to develop
interventions to get people to change
their dietary habits. They tend to focus
on the classroom partly because you want
large scale change and schools are one
of the rare opportunities to get access
to basically the entire population at a
at a given age. And so one thing that
these interventions basically all have
in common is that they involve some
combination of health and nutrition
education. So what's good for you, what's
bad for you, how do you read the
nutrition labels, and what's called
skills training. And that usually
involves a combination of learning how
to set realistic goals, analyzing
barriers to behavior change, that sort of
thing. The other big thing they all have
in common is that they've failed, right?
So people have been trying to do this
for like 30 years. I'm not aware of a
single intervention that keeps affecting
people's behavior after you stop
intervening.
And I think the major reason for this is
that they all share either implicitly or
explicitly an underlying assumption. And
that is that long term self-interest, the
desire to be healthy in the distant
future, is an effective motivator for
teenagers. And I mean I don't need
citations, but I have them, but like,
obviously that's not the case. And so our
approach has been to, rather than trying
to get adolescents to care about things
they don't care about, reframe the
meaning of healthy eating so that it's
consistent with the things they do care
about. We focus on three major values in
particular. One is the sort of
well-known teen drive to rebel against
adult authority. Adolescents hate doing
what adults tell them to do, they'll
often do the opposite just to reassert
their autonomy. Less widely-appreciated
is adolescence is a period where there's
a real increase in concern for fairness
and justice and beyond the self aims.
Just to give you a couple of quick
examples: this is the time in life when
people often first decide to become
vegetarians for moral reasons or
anti-globalization activists. They have a
sense of themselves as agents in the
world for the first time and they want
to make the world a better place. And
unlike most adults they're not yet jaded
about their prospects for doing that.
Yeah, this collection of optimistic
people was the wrong place to make that
cynical joke.
Okay and then the third
big value is gonna be familiar again,
that's the drive for peer approval and
status. It's certainly not unique to
adolescents but it actually is very
strongly heightened in adolescents. And a
big reason for that is that the
central task, developmental task of
adolescence, is figuring out how to be
a social agent. So if you're going to do
that, you need to be very attentive to
what's being approved of and what's not.
And so what we did to try to appeal to
these three values was essentially, it
took a two-fold approach. The first is we
framed the entire intervention as an
expose of manipulative food industry
marketing practices aimed at tricking
people into eating more junk food than
they would naturally be inclined to eat.
And here I'm talking about things like
using deceptive labeling to conceal the
sugar content in food or spending
unbelievable sums of money on
laboratories that are specifically
designed to figure out how you can
formulate foods to make them as
addictive as possible. The second thing
we did was emphasize the social justice
consequences of this food marketing. And
here I'm talking in particular about
disproportionately targeting very young
children, poor people and minorities with
marketing of the unhealthiest foods
because they're easy targets. And so our
goal here was to frame healthy eating as
a way to stick it to the man, to rebel
against a controlling adult authority
figure who's trying to control us, and as
a way to stand up for people who are
less able to defend themselves - both of
which were sort of deliberately
crafted to appeal to the to this sort of
adolescent set of values and
sensibilities. And so essentially what we
were aiming to do here was to
replace what we imagined adolescents'
sort of default construal, their default
understanding of what a healthy eater is.
Something like, "Healthy eaters are lame
nerds who do what adults tell them to do"
with an alternative construal: "Healthy
eaters are independent minded people who
are fighting to make the world a fairer
place."